bonjour jean jacques gendreau ski merci
de répondre à nos questions tout d'abord
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter de
l'apparition d'un premier cas confirmé
d'une contamination à la vaillante
industrie skov de à tour pas de preuve
que le vaccin ne soit pas efficace selon
les autorités sanitaires les chercheurs
généticien philippe froguel qu'on a eue
sur notre antenne récemment ne semblait
pas aussi catégorique
alors de toute façon il faut éviter
d'être catégorique en quoi que ce soit
avec ce virus puisque il ya encore un an
ne connaissait pas et on en apprend tous
les jours
néanmoins tout laisse à penser que les
mutations il y en a eu près de 30000
depuis un an n'ont pas atténué la
l'efficacité des vaccins puisqu'ils
s'adressent à la protéine spike la
fameuse protéine qui fait les petits et
puis les petits piquant si on peut dire
grâce auquel le virus se fixe sur des
cellules et il sent que cette protéine
soit la même ce petit pic en soit le
même quel que soit les mutations qui ont
eu lieu donc être catégorique ce serait
imprudent être raisonnablement certain
que le vaccin va fonctionner on peut
l'être
et de toute façon les producteurs du
vaccin ont indiqué qu'ils pourraient
modifier le cas échéant puisque ce
vaccin est fabriqué à partir de la
protéine en question si besoin en était
on pourrait modifier la chose et on
pourrait coupler le vaccin de l'ancienne
formulé de nouvelles
encore une fois il ya eu une nouvelle
technologie vaccinale un vaccin à arn ça
veut dire quoi exactement
ça veut dire que les vaccins
traditionnels sont fabriqués en prenant
une bactérie ou un virus dans le cas
particulier un virus pour prendre
l'exemple de la grippe et à l'atténuer à
le rendre inactif néanmoins identifiable
et donc on va fabriquer des anticorps
grâce à ce vaccin
et lorsqu'on sera en présence du virus
cette fois actif qu'on va être âpre à la
maladie eh bien les anticorps seront
déjà prêt et pourront lutter contre ce
virus
dans le cas du virus à arn dans le cas
du vaccin pardon à arn ce que l'on
fabrique c'est quelque chose qui va
s'opposer à l'intérieur du virus et non
pas du corps humain à la fabrication de
la protéine qui permet au virus de se
fixer à nos cellules
puisqu'un virus ne peut pas vivre tout
seul
a besoin de parasites et une cellule
vivante pour être à son tour à peu près
vivant si je puis dire
donc les vaccins arn sont effectivement
quelque chose que l'on connaissait en
théorie mais qu'on avait jamais mise en
pratique et qui pour la première fois on
en attend à ses records a pu être mis au
point
efficacité qui a été vérifié par avant
là avant la mise sur le marché
efficacité à 95% mais quid des 5%
restants et des effets indésirables
alors ça veut dire que tous les vaccins
ont un taux d'efficacité tiers de
protection de canton 10 95% ça veut dire
que 95% des sujets exposés avaient des
anticorps qui faisait en sorte qu'ils
n'attrapent pas la maladie c'est vrai de
n'importe quel vaccination qui
d'ailleurs en général ont des taux de
succès nettement inférieur 95% c'est un
taux exceptionnel cela dit les 5% qui ne
sont pas vaccinés au plus tôt qu'ils ne
sont pas protégés risque de développer
la maladie
au même titre que quelqu'un qui est
vaccinée contre la grippe sans que le
vaccin soit efficace risque d'attraper
la grippe
non effectivement auguin aucun
traitement préventif aucun vaccin
encore une fois un ado d'efficacité de
100% cela n'existe pas pas même pour le
bcg où les vaccins que nos enfants
subissent avant de pouvoir entrer à
l'école maternelle
les premières doses du vaccin donc le
vaccin de pfizer biotech sont arrivés
tout à l'heure en france on envoie des
images à vos côtés le les premières
injections doivent commencer demain à
dijon et à sevran sur des personnes à
risque volontaire mais en france selon
des récents sondages environ 60 à 70%
des personnes interrogées se disent
réticente à l'idée de se faire vacciner
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer aux
jeunes explique parce que il ya chez
nous un bruissement de complotiste et
d'anti vaque à assez sournois et assez
persistants les français sont suspicieux
par nature alors ils ont raison de ne
pas croire aveuglément tout et n'importe
quoi mais dans le cas particulier il
s'est trouvé qu'on a donné un large écho
à ce qui était anticipé un conte à
mélanger des choses qu'ils n'auraient
pas dû l'être comme les effets
secondaires de certains excipients ou à
du vent qu'on mettait jadis dans les
vaccins qui ne sont pas présents dans ni
le vaccin de pfizer ni le vaccin modern
art ni les vaccin gsk ni aucun des
vaccins en cours de mise au point
ce sont des technologiques ont été
abandonnées mais la rumeur persiste et
il se trouve que la communication vous
êtes un acteur de la communication comme
les autorités de santé sont propagea
suspicion puis j'entendais juste avant
que le journal ne commencent les bruits
de responsables politiques qui
confondent action politique et
opposition politique avec vérité
scientifique et qui tire parti de ce
moment pour critiquer la politique de
vaccination sous le seul prétexte que ce
n'est pas eux qui l'ont décidé
je trouve ça particulièrement désolant
beaucoup de pays on confine en europe ou
même en israël demain ou encore la
province de l'ontario au canada
la france est ce qu'elle est à
contre-courant certains observateurs et
politiques paris sur un continent après
les vacances de noël votre avis votre
pronostic
alors les pronostics c'est réservé pour
les gens qui commentent les courses
hippiques
moi je n'en fais pas sur la base des
données existantes
il n'ya rien enfin le gouvernement a
indiqué que son souhait n'était pas de
confiner les indicateurs qui sont
collectés minutieusement rigoureusement
contre paul est contrôlable ne n'indique
pas que la france soit dans la nécessité
de re confiné au lendemain des vacances
de noël
cela dit si les indicateurs se
détériorait et bien on serait sans doute
obligé de prendre une mesure sinon de
confinement du moins de durcissement de
la quarantaine est comme ça a été dit
sur votre antenne ya quelques minutes
peut-être de limiter les déplacements à
des gens qui soient aurait un test
négatif soit viendrait de se faire
vacciner
de manière à éviter la propagation en
particulier de cette souche une nouvelle
si elle existe vraiment et qu'elle est
vraiment une souche plus contaminantes
si je puis dire tout en entraînant une
maladie qui n'est pas plus grave au
premier aux premières observations qui
ont été réels
je crois que si vous voulez actuellement
les mesures qui sont prises sont des
mesures de vigilance des mesures de
prudence raisonnable qu'aller au-delà
serait céder à la panique et il n'y a
pas lieu
aller en deçà serait de l'inconscience
je pense mais absolument les mesures en
france sont bien calibrée merci jean
jacques hazan réussite est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin hospitalier à
l'hôpital bichat de paris et économiste
de la santé à l'université paris
descartes